Mary here with a gamespot news update it
looks like batman arkham knight is going
to be the first in the Rocksteady
Studios trilogy to get an M for Mature
rating because they're going to say [ __ ]
in it the first two games in the series
Batman Arkham Asylum and batman arkham
city both received t 14 ratings Arkham
Knight game director Sefton Hill said he
was surprised to hear the game got rated
M he said from our point of view we
never wrote it or made it with a rating
in mind we just felt like this is the
story that we wanted to tell while this
rating will mean younger fans will miss
out he said it would have been wrong to
water down the game and deliver story we
didn't believe in while the ESRB hasn't
yet revealed the reasons behind its
decision he'll seems to think that it
was the story elements rather than
gratuitous gore or swearing or explicit
pornography that got Arkham the M rating
he said we want to deliver a true end
with no compromises and that takes us to
some dark places earlier in the
development of the game it was revealed
that publisher Warner Bros told the
developer that certain scenes would
cause issues and might need to be cut
Hill was able to defend the scenes and
they stayed in the game adults and
irresponsible mothers can pick up batman
arkham knight on jun 2nd for the latest
in gaming news head to gamespot com
flash news